GO AHEAD TO OUR- IT IS ONE
THIRTY TWO SO LET ME CALL THE
AUGUST FOURTEENTH MEETING OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE TO ORDER
MAN SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES.
YOUR BATES HERE MONNING.
MONNING HERE ROTH ROTH HERE
WILK WILL CARE ATKINS ATKINS
HERE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO I'M GONNA ARE TRYING
TO ESTABLISH A CONSENT CALENDAR
AND WE'RE GONNA PULL ONE OF THE
ITEMS ARE OFF OF NUMBER TWO SO
IF WE COULD HAVE A MTION ON
ITEMS TO. C. D. F. G. H. N. I
THESE ARE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE
IS NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR. ITEM
NUMBER THREE WITH REFERENCE OF
BILLS ITEMS NUMBER FOUR THROUGH
TWELVE WHICH ARE FLOOR IT
KNOWLEDGE MEN'S. IF I COULD
HAVE A MOTION ON THAT. THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BATES. BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH
AYE WILK WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE AYE I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO EASY GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES. VOTING MORNING
MORNING I ROTH ROTH IRA WILK
WILK I ATKINS HI CONCISE. FOUR
ZERO THAT IS DONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES AND AS WE ARE
BRING UP OUR FIRST GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO APPEAR MS
CAN MAKE ME GO BURDEN FOR
MEMBER OF THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD AS YOU'RE GETTING.
SETTLED LET ME JUST TAKE A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
AND WELCOME BACK ARE FORMER PRO
TEM. JOHN BURTON WHOSE PICTURES
RIGHT UP THERE LAW. LOOKING
GOOD IS EVER I GUESS I CAN SAY
THE WELL I DON'T KNOW MAYBE I
NEED A MOTION TO SAY THAT. I
DON'T GET IN TROUBLE SENATOR
BUT WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE YOU
HERE FOR GIVE US FIVE NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEARTS AN
INSTITUTION. SO WELCOME. I SO
LET ME I INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF OBVIOUSLY
RECOGNIZE ANYONE WHO'S HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO AND THEN GO RIGHT INTO YOUR
COMMENTS AND THEN WE WILL. GO
FORWARD WITH QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FIRST. I'M.
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE I ACTUALLY
GOT ON INTERNATIONAL FLIGHT
LAST NIGHT AT EIGHT O'CLOCK SO
I'M A LITTLE I'M NOT ON MY A
GREAT A GREAT I CAN'T EVEN
SPEAK SO I APOLOGIZE IF I COME
ACROSS SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN
ENTERTAINING APPOINTMENT IS
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING US WE ARE
WE LOVE TO BE ENTERTAINED THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN MY FAMILY
SO. MY DAD IS HERE. I DROVE UP
THIS MORNING HE DIED. I GOT
GOOD MARKS FOR MAKING IT UP
HERE QUICKLY THERE WAS ACTUALLY
NO CONSTRUCTION BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SACRAMENTO HE
SAID NO THIS DAY IN HISTORY BUY
A LOTTERY TICKET WE GOT UP HERE
IN NOTHING FLAT. CELL I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE. WERE FIX.
BEFORE YOU ADD THIS AFTERNOON
AS THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE TO
THE STATE PERSONAL BOARD WHICH
AS YOU KNOW IS A
CONSTITUTIONALLY CREATED. FOR
THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING THE STATE'S CIVIL
SERVICE AMERICA. SYSTEM. I WAS
INITIALLY APPOINTED BY FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN SEVEN YEARS AGO
AND DURING MY TENURE ON THE
BOARD OUR PRIMARY FOCUS HAS
BEEN A CIVIL SERVICE
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CALLIE CHAR
AND GOV OPS THE BOARD IS MADE
SEVERAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM WE'VE
ABOLISHED OVER THOUSAND
OUTDATED CLASSIFICATIONS AND
CONSOLIDATED OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY CLASSIFICATIONS IN FIELDS
OF INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
RESEARCH AND SKILLED TRADES
WE'VE ALSO MADE IMPROVEMENT
DEFLECTIONS PROCESS THROUGH A
NUMBER OF REGULATORY AND POLICY
CHANGES INCLUDING REQUIRING
BROUGHT INCLUDES RECRUITMENT
STRATEGIES AND MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE APPLICATION METHODS TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CANDIDATES
TO APPLY FOR STATE SERVICE AND
ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS. IN
ADDITION OUR COMPLIANCE REVIEW
DIVISION HAS CONDUCTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY COMPLIANCE
REVIEWS OF DIFFERENT HR
DEPARTMENTS PRACTICES AND SEVEN
SPECIAL INTO. INVESTIGATIONS I
CAN READ INSTALLATION PROPRIETY
SUCH AS PRESELECTION EXAM. EXAM
CHEATING AND OPPORTUNISM WITH
RESPECT TO APPEALS THE BOARD
HAS DECIDED OVER TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED APPEALS FROM
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AND OVER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED MERIT APPEALS
DURING MY TENURE AND WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY MAINTAINED LITTLE
TO NO BACKLOG AND APPROXIMATELY
1% OF THE DECISIONS ISSUED BY
THE BOARD HAVING BEEN REVERSED
BY THE COURTS APPROXIMATELY 10%
ARE TAKEN UP ON APPEAL AND LESS
THAN 10% OF THOSE SO ABOUT 1%
OVERALL ARE OVERTURNED SO ARE.
AFFIRMATION RATE IS PRETTY GOOD
THE GREAT BATTING AVERAGE. AS
YOU MAY KNOW I SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER AS A GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE
I STARTED FRESH OUT OF LAW
SCHOOL AT THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE I WORK FOR THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION FOR THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE. FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I'VE BEEN
WITH THE CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS MANAGING THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM AND SO I THINK MY
PERSPECTIVE AS A GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE AND AS A MANAGER.
GIVES ME THE BALANCE IN THE
PERSPECTIVE NECESSARY. TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE BOARD MEMBER AND TO
RECOGNIZE. THE CASES THEY ARE
PRESENTED AS THEY ARE PRESENTED
AND RECOGNIZE IF THERE ARE ANY.
CHALLENGES TO THOSE CASES AND
KNOWING WHAT WOULD OR WOULD NOT
BE UP HELD BY PORTION SOMEBODY
TAKE ONE OF OUR DECISIONS ON.
IT ALLOWS ME TO EFFECTIVELY WAY
TO DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF THE
EMPLOYEE IN QUESTION AGAINST
THE INTERESTS OF THE STATE OF
HAVING THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST STATE EMPLOYEES. I
WISH TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR REAL POINTING
ME TO THE BEST TO THIS POSITION
AND I AM HAPPY TO BE BEFORE YOU
AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATE ROTH LET'S START WITH
YOU TODAY. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM RESOLUTIONS. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND FOR YOUR
CONTINUED WILLINGNESS TO. THE
CONTINUE SERVING OUR GREAT
STATE. JUST ONE QUESTION OF IN
MY TENURE HERE I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO THE CHAIR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT HAD OVERSIGHT
OVER OUR STATES IT PROJECTS AND
EARLY IN MY TENURE I REMEMBER
DEALING WITH THE STATE'S OF
PAYROLL OF. IT PROJECT THAT
DIDN'T MAKE IT ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE I'M SURE WE'LL
REVISIT THAT BUT ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT I REMEMBER BEING.
IT WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
DURING THAT OVERSIGHT PROCESS
WAS THE COMPLEXITY OF OUR-
PAYROLL SYSTEM CLASSIFICATIONS
SIMO USE AND THE LIKE. I KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'VE INDICATED AND YOU
HAVE MADE A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
EFFORT IN ATTEMPTING YOU IN THE
BOARD IN ATTEMPTING TO SIMPLIFY
THAT. OUR SYSTEM DO YOU HAVE
ANY POJECTED. COMPLETION DATE
WHAT'S THE PROGNOSIS IF YOU CAN
TELL ME WHAT THE CHALLENGE I
WAS MEETING WITH SENATOR MINING
AND HIS STAFF EARLIER PART OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT EVERYBODY
AS WE SIT HERE TODAY BELIEVES
IN CLASS CONSOLIDATION. EXCEPT
WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
THE CLASSES AND THEIR
DEPARTMENTS AND THEN A SORT OF
LIKE WHEN YOU WALKING
CONSOLIDATE BUT I WOULD
ACTUALLY LIKE TO KEEP MY HOME
AND SO WITH. IT BECOMES REALLY
AS- A LEADERSHIP QUESTION AT
HOUSE THE DEPARTMENT HAS HAVE
TO GET ON BOARD AND EVERYBODY
HAS TO BE ON BOARD WITH IT IF.
THERE ARE CONSOLIDATIONS THE
UNIONS GET AWAY AND EVERYBODY
GETS TO WIN AND SO IF THE IF
THE MESSAGE FROM ON HIGH IS
THAT THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
THERE'S HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH MORE. I
CAN'T GIVE YOU A DATE. IS THAT
THE MESSAGE THAT YOU WERE
CONSISTENTLY HEARING FROM ON
HIGH THAT IN FACT WE NEED TO DO
THIS. YES NO I MEAN I THINK
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DO IT AND I
THINK THAT IF WE ASK MOST
DEPARTMENT HAS THEY WOULD ALSO
AGREE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
CLASS CONSOLIDATION BUT WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND IN PRACTICE. IS THAT
DEPARTMENTS ARE A LITTLE MORE
RELUCTANT TO. TO GIVE UP THEIR
OWN CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE
EXAMPLE I USED EARLIER TODAY
WAS THAT OF A TURNS THEIR
ATTORNEYS AND MANY DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS. AND SO IF YOU HAVE
ONE ATTORNEY CLASSIFICATION YOU
COULD APPLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WHAT HAVE YOU.
BUT DEPARTMENT SAY WHAT I
ACTUALLY NEED MY OWN ATTORNEY
CLASSIFICATION YOU WALK AND
HAVE ONE FOR YOU BUT I REALLY A
SPECIAL ONE FOR ME BECAUSE IT
WOULD HELP EMPLOYEES. NO WHICH
DEPARTMENT THEY WERE APPLY FOR
IN THAT THE COUNTER ARGUMENT IS
THEN YOU APPLY TO THAT
DEPARTMENT YOU. PASS THE TEST
AND IF YOU WANT TO BE IN
ATTORNEY GENERAL YOU APPLY FOR
THAT DEPARTMENT IF YOU WANT TO
WORK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR YOU DO THAT BUT THERE IS.
THERE DEFINITELY ARE CHALLENGES
WHERE DEPARTMENTS FEEL LITTLE
PROTECTIVE OF THEIR OWN
CLASSIFICATIONS EVEN THOUGH
GLOBALLY THEY SUPPORT THE IDEA.
SO IT IS IT'S A CHALLENGE AND I
THINK IT COMES THE DECISIONS.
THE IMPETUS IS GONNA HAVE TO
COME FROM LEADERSHIP WE START
MAKING THOSE. WELL I FOUND. I
CERTAINLY AGREE AND IF IT IS
TRUE THAT. THE COMPLEXITY OF
OUR PAYROLL SYSTEM AND
CLASSIFICATIONS IN MO USE
CLASSIFICATIONS OF SEVERAL A
CONTRIBUTES TO SOME OF OUR
DIFFICULTY IN FIELDING NEW IT
SYSTEMS PARTICULARLY IN THE HR
AND PAYROLL AREA WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET
A HANDLE ON THAT AND I COMMEND
YOU. AND YOUR FELLOW BOARD
MEMBERS FOR ATTEMPTING TO DO SO
AND I CERTAINLY THE X. IT
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO AN
EXPECTED ADMINISTRATION TO BE
FULLY SUPPORTIVE AND- PROVIDE
THAT SORT OF TOP DOWN GUIDANCE
THAT YOU'VE BEEN REFERRING TO
SO THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO.
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME VERY MUCH.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
A MATTER PRO TEM ARE
CONGRATULATIONS ON ON YOUR RE
APPOINTMENT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING IT AND I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
EXCELLENT QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES. OKAY
GREAT LET ME ON MY
CONGRATULATIONS AND LOOKING OUT
TO THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE SERVED
THIS BURDEN AT VERY SIGNIFICANT
HERE THE INSTITUTIONAL SHINDO
CERTAINLY THAT IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT IN THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING ON YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT HOW WE USED TO DO IT IS HOW
WE'VE IMPROVED FROM I THINK
IT'S TWENTY TWELVE IS THAT
CORRECT YES BACK FANTASTIC SO
MY QUESTION WOULD PROBABLY BE
JUST THAT PERSPECTIVE YOU CAME
IN TWENTY TWELVE ALONG PRETTY
YOUNG. WHILE YOU KNOW NOT TOO
LONG. OUT OF COLLEGE AND YOU
SEEN THOUGH YOU'RE VERY KIND.
ONE WOMAN WE CARE ABOUT THOSE
THINGS RIGHT AS LONG AS- BUTI
THINK THAT IT WOULD BE GOOD TO
JUST GET A QUICK PERSPECTIVE ON
THE AGENCY NOW OUT WITH A LOT
OF THE NEW REGULATIONS THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD FOR LABOR
ALSO SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALL OF
THAT. HOW D YOU SEE ON YOUR
THE AGENCY OR YOUR ASSIGNMENT
TO KIND OF FROM TWENTY TWELVE
TO THE PRESENT BEING BETTER IN
TERMS REPRESENTING CERTAINLY
THE PEOPLE. AND THE EMPLOYEES
AND THE WHOLE SYSTEM. SO I'D
ONE OF THE CHANGES IS WHEN I
FIRST CAME IT WAS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE. THE
REORGANIZATION THAT LET S. P.
B. AND CAL H. ARE OFTEN TO TWO
DIFFERENT APARTMENTS AND SO
THAT YOU HAVE STARTED I THINK
RIGHT BEFORE I CAME ON AND SO
SORT OF SEEING HOW THOSE
ENTITIES ARE BECOMING SEPARATE
AND YET. REALLY QUITE
INTERTWINED. SO THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY ABOUT
THE RULES NOW THAN THEY WERE
BECAUSE IT WAS SORT OF THAT. IT
WAS THAT A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
THERE WAS REALLY NO BLUEPRINT
BECAUSE IT HADN'T BEEN DONE
BEFORE WHAT WHAT I HAVE SEEN IN
TERMS OF THE ABOUT INDEPENDENT
BEST OCCASIONS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING INTO
DEPARTMENTS EVERY THREE YEARS
THAT'S NEW AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S HELPFUL IT WILL HELP US
IDENTIFY TRENDS. GOOD AND BAD
HELP US IDENTIFY I'M FROM THE
BEST PRACTICES IN DEPARTMENTS
AND ALSO WITH ONGOING TRAININGS
THAT NEED TO BE DONE LIKE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AS YOU
MENTIONED. AND HELPING TO MAKE
SURE I MEAN WHAT WE ARE IS THE
ENTITY TO SORT OF SHINE A
BRIGHT LIGHT WHEN SOMETHING
GOES POORLY IT IS AS I WAS
SAYING EARLY SORT OF UP TO THE
LEADERSHIP TO SAY. YOU NEED TO
DO THIS BUT AS HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
A BRIGHT LIGHT WAS SHOWN AND-
SO CHANGES WERE MADE TO THE WAY
THAT THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
FRANKLY DOES BUSINESS NOW AND I
THINK THAT THAT CERTAINLY
WASN'T. EXCLUSIVELY BECAUSE OF
S. P. B. BUT THE INVESTIGATION
THAT THE HARD WORKING. STAFF
MEMBERS AT THAT AGENCY DID WAS
WAS CERTAINLY A BIG PART OF
THAT AND- WE WOULD HOPE WOULD
GIVE OTHER AGENCIES ENGAGING IN.
DUBIOUS PRACTICES A LITTLE BIT
OF PAUSE WOULD NOT WANT TO BE
SORT OF SEE THEIR NAMES IN THE
HEADLINES ARE BE BROUGHT BEFORE
THE SNOW INVITED TO EXPLAIN
THEMSELVES TO THE BOARD AND SO
I THINK THAT THAT IS IF
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN WORKING
OUT WELL FOR US. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE OF FIVE CERTAINLY
MERITORIOUS AND A LENGTHY AND
WE APPRECIATE. THAT SO
CONGRATULATIONS. MY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES SENATOR MINING THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND AGAIN
APPRECIATED OUR CHANCE TO GET
ACQUAINTED THIS AFTERNOON AND
WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU ON
YOUR REAPPOINTMENT THANK YOU
FOR STEPPING UP FOR ANOTHER
ROUND. OF PUBLIC SERVICES TO
APPRECIATED THEM AS WE
DISCUSSED BRIEFLY AND I THINK
WOULD BE OF INTEREST TO MEMBERS
OF THE- OF THE RULES COMMITTEE.
SOME BASED ON SURVEYS BY STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT WAS DETERMINED THAT
NEARLY 60% OF AGENCIES DID NOT
PROVIDE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING. IN THAT SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE STATE PERSONAL
BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED STATE GOVERNMENT
SUPERVISORS DOZENS OF AGENCIES
WHO DID NOT RECEIVE THE
REQUIRED TRAINING. SO WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION BASED ON
SURVEYS DONE BY SPT BUT WHAT DO
YOU HAVE ANY AUTHORITY TO MOVE
THEM INTO ACTION IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS IS NOT A VERY ENCOURAGING.
COMPLAINTS THE DATA OF DOING
TRAINING THAT COULD BOTH
PROTECT EMPLOYEES FROM UNWANTED
HARASSMENT LAWS TO PROTECT THE
STATE FROM POTENTIAL LIABILITY.
WE'RE SORT OF LIKE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CHANNELS HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE SEVEN ON YOUR
SIDE IT'S LIKE INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM AND THEY GO IN AND
SO IF YOUR DEPARTMENT HAS FIFTY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT GONE
THROUGH THE TRAINING AND YOU
KNOW THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO GO THROUGH THE
TRAINING. WE EXPOSE THAT WE
BRING YOU AND IF IT IF IT
WARRANTS THAT WE BRING YOU WENT
BEFORE THE BOARD AND HAVE YOU
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
DIDN'T FEEL WAS A PRIORITY FOR
YOUR EMPLOYEES TO COMPLY WITH
THE LINE WITH THOSE MANDATED
TRAINING DIRECTIVES. AT THE END
OF THE DAY IF IT WERE. IF THE
ISSUE WERE SUCH THAT THE
GOVERNOR THOUGHT IT WARRANTED
THAT THE GOVERNOR COULD REPLACE
THE DEPARTMENT HEAD OR-
MANAGERS COULD BE REPLACED BY
THEIR DEPARTMENT. HANG ON WHAT
THE ISSUE IS OUR JOB IS REALLY
TO EXPOSE THAT AND TO. MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
THERE ND THAT THEY NEED TO DO
IT BUT TO EXPOSE ANYTHING THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN. WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK. IT
IT LEAST PROVIDES A STARTING
POINT THE- ACTION NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN WHETHER THAT'S BY THE
LEGISLATURE OR- OTHER STATE
AGENCIES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THIS JUST SEEMS
UNACCEPTABLE IN OUR- CURRENT
CLIMATE IN ITS IT'S A
DISSERVICE TO EMPLOYEES IN A
DISSERVICE TO TAXPAYERS AS WELL.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO SHARE
JUST MOVING FORWARD PRIORITIES
CONCERNS. I THINK I ASKED YOU
IF YOU HAD A MAGIC WAND HAD A
MAGIC WAND IF I HAD A MAGIC
WAND EVERYBODY WOULD. EVERYBODY
WOULD LISTEN AND EVERYBODY
WOULD DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO EVERYBODY WOULD DO THE
TRAINING THE MANAGERS WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR EMPLOYEES
DID AT THE HIGHER LEVEL
MANAGERS WOULD MAKE SURE THOSE
MANAGERS DID IT ON THE
DEPARTMENT HEADS WOULD MAKE
SURE. AND ULTIMATELY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THOSE IN
CHARGE ARE DOING BACK WHICH
THEY CHARGE TO DO I MEAN THIS
IS THIS IS A- A PUBLIC CHARGE
THERE AND TRUSTED WE AS
TAXPAYERS PAY THEIR SALARIES.
AND I HAVE RULES THAT WORK AND
THEY HAVE RULES AT WORK AND IF
I DON'T. RULES AT WORK I DON'T
GET TO HAVE MY JOB ANYMORE I'M
IT WILL SO I ACTUALLY DON'T.
DON'T HAVE THAT SAME PROCESS
BUT YOU MAYBE THERE SHOULD BE A-
YOU DON'T GET YOUR PAYCHECK IF
YOU HAVEN'T. THEN THE TRAINING
THAT'S REQUIRED AND IF I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO COMMENT ON THAT
GOOD. YOU KNOW. MADAM CHAIR I
DON'T HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS
I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
NOMINATION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES LET ME TURN TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND ASK
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
TO COME UP. A STATE YOUR NAME
ON MY COMMENTS YOU MIGHT BE
HERE ON BEHALF OF. THANK THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE BAKER THIRD REDUCE
OF SEATS REPRESENTING THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT. WE WERE
HERE SEVEN YEARS AGO TO SUPPORT.
MS BURTON SHE'S DONE A GREAT
JOB SINCE THEN I WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT AN EASY JOB
DEALING WITH CLASSIFICATIONS
AND DISCIPLINE AFFECT PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND LIVELIHOOD AND- MISS
BURDENS BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
WITH A COMMON. WITH OUR SUPPORT
TO INCREASE THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE OR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME TURN MEMBERS ABOVE ZERO
AND WE HAVE THE NATIONAL UNION
HEALTH CARE WORKERS SITTING IN
NATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES HERE IN SUPPORT
OF MISS BURDENS APPOINTMENT A
REAPPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE JUST
HERE FOR MORAL SUPPORT MISTER
PRO TEM. YOU DON'T SPEAK. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. ISSUES. OURS ARE
MOTHER MASSIVE AND HER FATHER
HAD. WELL SAID ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NONE
ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
ROTH LEAVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES AYE BATES AYE
MONNING AYE MONNING AYE ROSS
ROSS I WILL WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
MS BURTON CONGRADULATIONS
UNANIMOUS. OKAY I DON'T GET OUT.
THANK YOU WAS HONOR TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE YOU SEE JOHN. WELL
WELCOME HELLO HOW ARE NOT IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE WE WILL
MOVE TO OUR SECOND ITEM
JONATHAN AND I'M GONNA SAY
SERVICE YOUR SIR PLEASE CORRECT
ME THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH SERVICE
SERVICE OKAY WELCOME AND YOU
AYE CONGRADULATIONS APPOINTMENT
TO THE UC BOARD OF REGIONS SO
WELCOME PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT'S HERE
WITH YOU GO RIGHT INTO WHAT
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH US AND THEN WE WILL YOU'VE
SEEN HOW THAT HAPPENS WE'LL GET
RIGHT INTO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM AND I'LL BE VERY BRIEF. AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE OTHER
SENATORS ON THE COMMITTEE MANY
OF WHO TOOK TIME OUT OF THEIR
VERY BUSY DAYS TO MEET WITH ME
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. MY NAME
IS JONATHAN J. SERVICE AND
HERE'S TODAY WITH ME IS MY
EIGHTY SIX YEAR OLD MOTHER
CHOICE FOR US. ONE OF MY FOUR
SISTERS JENNIFER JACOB VOWELS.
AND TO MY SIGNIFICANT OTHER AND
BEST FRIEND OF MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS B. J. TOPOL AND HER
SISTER TAMMY. BEACH AND I AND
TAMMY ALL MET WHEN WE WERE
UNDERGRADUATES AT UCLA. LET ME
SAY THE DISAPPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN BY FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN AND WHOLE
HEARTEDLY ENDORSED BY GAVIN BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS PERHAPS THE
GREATEST HONOR OF MY LIFE. AND
TRULY MEANS THE WORLD TO ME
I'VE HAD DEEP TIES TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. SINCE
MY DAYS THERE AND I'M
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THE INSTITUTION
HAS GIVEN ME. I WOULD NOT BE
SITTING HERE TODAY. WITHOUT THE
WORLD CLASS EDUCATION THAT I
RECEIVED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. VERY BRIEFLY DURING
MY TENURE AS A REGION. I WOULD
HOPE TO ACCOMPLISH A FEW GOALS
NUMBER ONE. MAKE THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AFFORDABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS I BELIEVE THE
QUALIFIED STUDENTS SHOULD GET
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT I
GOT. NUMBER TWO I'D LIKE TO
HELP ENHANCE AND EXPAND THE
REACH OF YOU SEE HEALTH. THE
SYSTEM THIS HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
HAS HAD A DIRECT IMPACT ON MY
FAMILY. AND IN IN MORE WAYS
THAN ONE AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT QUALITY HEALTHCARE IS A
RIGHT NOT A PRIVILEGE. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED THE
EXPERTISE OF YOU CA YOU SEE
HEALTH. CAN RECEIVE IT. AND
LASTLY WITH THE PASSING OF
FORMER REGENT TAUSCHER MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE APOINTED ME AS
THE NEW VICE CHAIR OF THE
NATIONAL LABORATORY COMMITTEE.
AS RESULT I WANT TO MAINTAIN
AND GROW UC'S OVERSIGHT OF
THESE TRULY REMARKABLE.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY LABS AND
PROVIDE THAT PROVIDE INNOVATION.
AND NATIONAL SECURITY AND
SAFETY. TO NOT JUST OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS BUT TO THE WORLD AS A
WHOLE. ALL OF THOSE GOALS ARE
ATTAINABLE THEIR MEASURABLE. AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
I INTENDTO BE INSISTENT
CONSISTENT AND PERSISTENT IN MY
PURSUIT TO EXECUTE THE DUTIES
AS REGION IN THE MOST HONORABLE
WAY I KNOW HOW. SO TO THAT AND
LET ME ON THE END WHERE I BEGAN
AND SAM HONOR TO BE HERE AND
I'M OPEN TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET ME START THIS TIME
WITH YOU SENATOR MONNING. THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM IN THANK YOU
MISTER SERVICE FIRST FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE SERVING
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN. IN
THE CAPACITY THAT YOU JUST
OUTLINED. WITH THE FURTHER
ASSIGNMENT WITHIN THE BOARD OF
REGENTS I ENJOYED OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPARE NOTES
AND ARE. RELATIVE TUITION FEES
WE ONLY ATTENDED UC CAMPUSES
DON'T TELL YOU WHAT WHAT I
DIDN'T PAY WHEN I WAS THERE.
BUT IT'S THE FINEST INSTITUTE
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD ONE OF THINGS WE DID
DISCUSS THAT I THINK WOULD BE
OF INTEREST TO. FELLOW MEMBERS
OF THE RULES COMMITTEE. THE
BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING
FIRST AMENDMENT FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS ANA AND PROTECTING THE
SECURITY AND SAFETY OF STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF HAD A WE-
ENDEAVOR TO PRESERVE THE RIGHT
BUT PROTECT THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY THANK YOU CENTER AS WE
SPOKE ABOUT I DID MEET WITH THE
A DL ONE OF THE FIRST MEETINGS
I TOOK AS A REGION WAS WITH THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. MY
MOTHER WAS A EXPERIENCE
EXTRAORDINARY ANTI SEMITISM IN
HER YOUTH. I THINK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR ON ONE HAND WE HAVE HATE
SPEECH AND ON THE OTHER SIDE WE
HAVE FREE SPEECH AND I THINK
THE JOB OF REGION'S IS TO FIND
THE MIDDLE LINE WHERE EVEN
UNPOPULAR VOICES CAN BE HEARD
AND ALLOWED TO SPEAK BUT TO THE
POINT WHERE SOMEONE'S LIFE IS
IN DANGER OR ITS INCITING
VIOLENCE I'M JUST NEVER GOING
TO ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN UNDER
MY WATCH I THINK IT'S VERY
CLEAR SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO SAY
THAT THAT MIDDLE LINE IS
DIFFICULT TO FIND. I DON'T
THINK SO I THINK HATE SPEECH IS
HATE SPEECH IT HAS. ZERO CLICKS.
THERE'S NO PLACE ON THE CAMPUS
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND- ON THE OTHER HAND I DO
WANNA AS UNPOPULAR AS IT IS TO
HEAR SOME SPEAKERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. I THINK
WE HAVE TO GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY I THINK THAT'S
THEIR RIGHT BUT THEY JUST
CANNOT INCITE VIOLENCE AND
THAT'S HOW I DRAW THE LINE.
THANK YOU ANOTHER AREA THAT WE
DID TOUCH ON TO IS. LOOKING AT.
RELATIVE ENROLLMENT FIGURES TO
VARIOUS. MINORITY POPULATIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE RELATIVELY LOW ON
ENROLLMENT RATES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS YOU SHARED SOME
THOUGHT SON. HELLO HELLO WE CAN
REMEDY NOT ONLY ACCESS BUT
RETENTION. SOME OF THEM MAY BE
INTERNAL REFORMS NECESSARY TO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
CONDUCIVE TO. REFLECTING THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YES
AFRICAN AMERICAN. ENROLLMENT IS
LOW I DON'T CARE WHAT ANYBODY
SAYS EVEN THOUGH IT'S GOING UP
IT'S ONLY A FOUR FOUR AND A
HALF PERCENT IT'S UP FROM SIX
YEARS AGO BUT IT SHOULD BE UP
HIGHER I THINK THERE'S MANY
ISSUES AT PLAY HERE I THINK WE
NEED TO REALLY DEVELOP SOME OF
THE SUMMER PROGRAM SO HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS CAN COME TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO GO
TO COLLEGE SO IT'S NOT SUCH A
SCARY THINGS THAT THEY FEEL
SAFER THERE I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE MENTORSHIP ON CAMPUS
AND WHEN I MEAN MENTORSHIP NOT
JUST STUDENT MENTORSHIP. WE
HAVE TO GROW OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN FACULTY AND STAFF SO
THAT FACULTY AND STAFF CAN.
MENTOR STUDENTS THAT'S HOW THEY
FEEL SAFE IN AN UNFAMILIAR
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S OBVIOUS
FINANCIAL AID IS AN ISSUE WITH
WE HAVE A TRUCK TREMENDOUS.
COMPETITION ISSUES WITH SOME OF
THE PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES AND I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND
WAYS AROUND THAT THAT IT'S
TRICKY. AND THE LAST THING IS
YOU KNOW THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS OUTRAGE ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOLS. FOR
COLLEGE PREP AND TO REALLY
EDUCATE STUDENTS ON WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO BE AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THAT'S A GOOD NUMBER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HOW PRODUCTIVE
IT IS NOT SOMETHING I WANT TO
LOOK INTO I MIGHT. COME BACK TO
AND SAY. LET'S HAVE THREE
HUNDRED SCHOOLS BUT LET'S DO IT
WELL. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE DIGGING INTO AN WHICH IS
THAT WAS SOMETHING WE SPOKE
ABOUT IN OUR LAST MEETING.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS I DID WANT TO LEAVE
IT ALL CONCLUDE BY. ALSO
THINKING YOUR FAMILY FOR THEIR
SUPPORT IN. GIVING YOU THE
SUPPORT TO FURTHER SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO MUCH
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND
THANK YOU TO THE FAMILY. THANK
YOU SENATOR BAIT. THANK YOU AND
DODD THANK YOU MISTER SIR IS
FOR ACTUALLY STEPPING FORWARD
INTO A VERY VERY CHALLENGING
POSITION ESPECIALLY AT THIS
TIME AND I THINK IN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BOTH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE WE HAD A GREAT
MEETING HE WAS ON THE HOT SEAT
YOU GUYS BUT AFTER THE
QUESTIONS I FELT LIKE I WAS SO
WE HAD A REALLY GOOD EXCHANGE
AND I THINK WE FOUND. THE WITH
MOST MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS TO
BE IN HERE AS YOU MAY ALL KNOW
AND CERTAINLY WITH THE UC
SYSTEM IS THE GROWTH OF WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE THE BUREAUCRACY
I DO BELIEVE THAT IT IMPAIRS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
VISION OF THE LEGISLATORS WHO
SET THE RULES IN THE RANKS THAT
MASS RESPOND TO THE PEOPLE WE
COME HERE TO SERVE IN HERE AND
YOU SEE ARE WE SEE A GROWTH OF
ADMINISTRATION OVER. THE TEN
YEAR JOB PROFESSORS AND WHAT I
CONSIDER ACADEMIA THE STAFF AND
WE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THAT AND I DID MENTION I'D LIKE
YOU TO SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT AND WHAT THE REGION'S
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO TO
BASICALLY KIND OF RAIN INDIANA
AND BRING SOME BALANCE BACK YES
THANK YOU CENTER. BATES THE
BUREAUCRACY IS FRUSTRATING. YOU
ALL ARE INVOLVED IN GOVERNMENT
ON A DAILY BASIS I'M IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WE DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY I THINK WHEN I LOOK
AT THE BUREAUCRACY THERE ARE
MOMENTS WHEN I WANT TO LOSE MY
HAIR. AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
DONE AND I GIVE CREDIT SAID
GAVIN TO GOVERNOR BROWN INTO.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME YOU DO NEED
SOME PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
PRIVATE PRACTICE ON THE BOARD
OF REGENTS THAT CAN GIVE THAT
LEVEL OF EXPERTISE. WHOEVER
SAID THAT THIS WAS A RUBBER
STAMP BOARD I DON'T MAYBE IT
WAS THREE YEARS AGO. IT'S NOT
NOW AS I'VE TOLD A NUMBER OF
YOU IN PRIVATE SESSION WE GO
OUT WITH ONE ANOTHER THERE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW
ON THAT BOARD. BUREAUCRACY IS A
BIG ISSUE I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT. WHERE SOME OF
THE BUREAUCRACY HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN WE ARE GOING
LINE BY LINE ON THAT BUDGET AND
SAYING IS THIS NECESSARY. DO WE
NEED IT AND IS IT WORTH IT. AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO DO THAT
I THINK THAT. IT TAKES TIME AS
A NEWLY APPOINTED REGION. IT
TAKES TIME TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE BUREAUCRACY IS AND WHAT'S
WORKING WELL AND THE ONLY THING
I CAN DO IS LOOK AT YOU IN THE
EYE AND SAY I'M GONNA DIG DEEP
INTO THAT. AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE RUNNING THE MOST
EFFICIENT ORGANIZATION WE
POSSIBLY CAN. AND I AM SURE
THAT YOU WILL AFTER OUR OUR I
THINK FORTY FIVE MINUTE
DISCUSSION WE HAVE FULL THANK
YOU AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN
AND YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT
THANK CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN. BUT THEY CAME
OUT APPROACH HIM FIRST OF ALL
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO INNOVATION I MEAN
I THINK THAT'S WHAT SETS
CALIFORNIA APART FROM THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY AND I KNOW I
TALK TO YOU ABOUT A CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE OF AEROSPACE SOME
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THAT FACTOR RATED UCLA
AFTER OUR MEETING SO. SOUNDS
GOOD TO ME BUT THAT NIGHT LET
THEM KNOW THAT YOUR YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS AS WELL.
OBVIOUSLY AS YOU KNOW FROM THE
CONSTITUTION THAT. YOU GUYS ARE
IN TO GET OPERATE
INDEPENDENTLY. ENGINE I'M IS
GIVING YOU AN ANECDOTAL STORY
AND I. HAVE NO DATA EVEN BACK
IT UP BUT I. COUPLE YEARS AGO I
RAN TAKEN STATION OF MINE IN
THE ANNALS VALLEY. HAS A
DAUGHTER EXCELLENT ACADEMICALLY
FOUR POINT WHATEVER. A LIFELONG
DREAM YET TO BERKELEY DID I GET
INTO BERKELEY GOT INTO
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN. HER
COUSIN WHO LIVES IN MICHIGAN.
GUIDED TO BERKELEY AND. SO
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM I UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO HAVE OUT OF STATE
AND IN THEIR SAW A CULTURAL
ENRICHMENT ASPECT AS WELL SO
BUT WAS SO WHAT DO YOU WHAT
YOUR VIEW IN TERMS OF PROPER
PROPER MIX THERE WE HAVE A MIX
RIGHT NOW IT'S A IT'S AT 18% I
MEAN FOR CERTAIN SCHOOLS IT'S
GONE UP. I THINK THERE IS AN
ASPECT OF DIVERSITY FROM OUT OF
STATE OUT OF COUNTRY I THINK
SOMETIMES PEOPLE REFER TO ADD A
STATE BUT I THINK IN THAT IN
THAT CATEGORY OUT OF COUNTRIES
A PORTION OF IT. I BELIEVE WE
SHOULD HAVE THE DIVERSITY OF
OUT OF STATE NOT A COUNTRY I
ALSO. WE HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND SAY THAT OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS TO HELP SUPPORT
IN STATE STUDENTS THEIR TUITION
DOES AND I THINK THAT'S
VALUABLE BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
WALK THE FINE LINE. WE SOME OF
THE SCHOOLS HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR
CAP. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
CURRENTLY IF THE US FAM. SCHOOL
EXCEEDS THEIR CAP OF OUT OF
STATE THE ACCESS FUNDS THE
DIFFERENTIAL GOES BACK TO THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT THAT
THEN CAN BE USED FOR OTHER
SCHOOLS I THINK THAT'S-
REASONABLE. AND I THINK THAT WE
JUST AS A BORDER GOING TO HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RIGHT
NUMBER AS A LOT OF THAT IS
GOING TO BE BUDGETARY BASED AND
I THINK AS ALL OF US ALL
REGIONS HAVE THE OBLIGATION. I
THINK WE SIT HERE BEFORE YOU
AND SAY OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA EDUCATES THE MOST
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS QUALIFY
CALIFORNIANS POSSIBLE AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M COMMITTED TO
DO. BREAK SO A SOFA SO OF A
FOLLOW UP ON THAT SEE RECENTLY
VOTED TO INCREASE TUITION ON
OUT OF STATE OUT OF COUNTRY
STUDENTS WHAT FACTORS WOULD YOU
CONSIDER MAKING ASSESSMENT IF
WE NEEDED TO RAISE TUITION FOR
IN STATE STUDENTS. HI VOTED ON
THAT MEASURE WAS A SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT DOLLAR
INCREASE FOR OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS THAT HADN'T BEEN
RAISED IN SOMETIME. AND WANT TO
DO IT IT WOULD HAVE LED TO A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL AND NO ONE HAD A GOOD
ANSWER OF HOW THAT WAS GONNA
MAY BE MADE UP SO THAT'S WHY I
VOTED FOR. UP IN STATE. WE TALK
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME IT'S THE
MOST TALKED ABOUT QUESTIONS AND
THE BOARD OF REGENTS IS ABOUT
RAISING TUITION ON IN STATE IN.
A STUDENTS. I THINK IT WILL BE
THE LAST THING ANY OF US WILL
WANT TO DO. I THINK THAT THERE
WILL BE. CONTROLLING THERE WILL
BE MOVING MONIES AROUND
ANYTHING POSSIBLE TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING. INEVITABLY
THOUGH IT WILL HAPPEN. AND I
THINK IT'S JUST GONNA REQUIRE
LEADERSHIP. I AM INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSED BY YOUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE JOHN FOR AS HIS OUR
NEW CHAIRMAN ON HIS GRASP OF
THIS MATTER AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF A COUPLE OF
REGION'S WHO HAVE BEEN AROUND
THE BLOCK HERE. ANNA TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE DON'T DO THAT AND
HOW WE CAN KEEP IT AFFORDABLE
IT'S EXPENSIVE. BUT IT'S STILL
A GOOD DEAL IN COMPARISON TO
OTHER PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
CERTAINLY PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY. BUT LET ME
JUST SAY ONE LAST THING I DON'T
WANT TO RAISE TUITION IS THE
LAST THE LAST THING I WANT TO
DO AND I'M COMMITTED TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN BEFORE THAT
HAPPENS OKAY. HEY BY THE WAY I
WANTED NICE TIE. BUT HE HE SAID
TO ME THAT MY TIE LOOKS TOO
MUCH LIKE TUCKER CARLSON'S
TÁI. WHICH WAS AS ABOUT AS
OFFENSIVE AS YOU THINK YOU
COULD SAY TO ME. SO WE WERE
JUST SAID ALL ALL ALL DEAL WITH
A LOT IT DOESN'T TRIGGER
ANYBODY WERE GOOD YEAH. GOOD
ANYWAY PREPARATION OUR TIME
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR- RECONFIRMATION TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER LOOK.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM A
CONGRATULATIONS I ACTUALLY HAVE
NO QUESTIONS I AM VERY VERY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR. RESUME IF
WE HAD MORE TIME I'D LIKE TO
ASK ABOUT A FEW OF THOSE THINGS
DID A FASCINATION AND NOTHING
ELSE I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN YOUR NEW POSITION
AND MEN APPROACHED HIM I LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THE
CONFIRMATION AN- APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR. I
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
I MAY BE FOLLOWING ALONG ON
THE- THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE.
BEEN IN RELATION TO THE
BUREAUCRACY IN THE BOARD AND-
YOU MADE A COMMENT IT'S NOT A
RUBBER STAMP BOARD AND I'M
PRETTY CLEAR I'VE SEEN THE
APPOINTMENTS THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN MADE. IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
KIND OF AN ENVIRONMENT AND
ATMOSPHERE ON THE BOARD. I
WANTED TO ASK FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE- I ACTUALLY
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF REGENTS
WHEN I WAS SPEAKER FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME. AND I ALWAYS FELT THAT
THE ENVIRONMENT WAS NOT VERY
INVITING FOR PEOPLE WHO CAME TO
SPEAK. NINE AND FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT DOES THATFEEL
LIKE IS THAT ALSO CHANGING I
WOULD REALLY HOPE BECAUSE- I
REALLY THINK ARE. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO COME TO SPEAK CALM
FOR A REASON US YOU KNOW A IT
BUT SOME REALLY IT'S THEIR
OPPORTUNITY BUT HEARD AND I
ALWAYS FELT LIKE IT WAS A VERY.
COLD PLACE IT IS SENATOR I
AGREE WITH YOU IT IS VERY COLD
PEOPLE GIVEN ONE MINUTE TO
SPEAK. A BUZZER GOES OFF. IT'S
UNFORTUNATE WE'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO RESPOND TO THE QUESTIONS AT
THAT MOMENT ALTHOUGH. OUR
SECRETARY DOES TAKE NOTES WE
GET A- A BRIEFING MATERIAL.
PACKET AFTERWARDS WHERE WE CAN
RESPOND TO THE INDIVIDUAL.
CONSTITUENTS TO COME UP AND GET
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I AGREE WITH
YOU I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE HAD SECURITY ISSUES THERE
SO THERE'S- MANAGEMENT OF
SECURITY ISSUES I GIVE IT TO
CHAIR PEREZ WHO. I THOUGHT
THERE WAS OVER SECURITY FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND THE NEW
SHARE HAS REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF
SECURITY THERE I THINK. THE
SHEER VOLUME OF POLICE OFFICERS
THERE MAKES IT VERY UNINVITING
WHEN YOUR A STUDENT TO GO
PRESENT FROM THIS BOARD I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LOOK AT AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT ON I'M HAPPY TO TALK
TO. CHAIR PRESS ABOUT IT I
THINK IT'S AN ISSUE. THANK YOU
ARE I EAT LOOK I. UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE ISSUES GET TO BE
QUITE. DIFFICULT IN TERMS OF
DISCUSSION SO. CERTAINLY
SECURITY IS ONE THING THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND HOW
YOU. STRIKE THE BALANCE OF
MAKING PEOLE FEEL WELCOME
DESPITE THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
TO CONSIDER ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS. I AM THRILLED ABOUT THE
BOARD IN THEIR REGIONS AND- THE
APPOINTMENTS IN THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE NOW TO GRAPPLE WITH
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BRING UP. I AT THE
STATE. OF THINGS THAT WERE IN
TUITION IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE HOW TO TRY TO KEEP IT
DOWN. AND AFFORDABLE AND A
CERTAINLY THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION. AS WELL AS HELL
WERE ABLE TO SUPPLEMENT OF
FINANCIAL AID AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. THE ISSUES OF ARM. THE
PERCENTAGE OF OUT OF STATE NOW
OUT OF OUR COUNTRY STUDENTS. I
THINK THAT THE REGION'S HAVE
RELEASE. STRIVE VERY HARD IN
THE LAST USED TO DEAL WITH ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE I SEE REAL MOVEMENT.
I JUST I JUST WONDERED HOW
PEOPLE FELT WHEN THEY WERE ABLE
TO COME IN AND SPEAK BECAUSE I.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THOUGHT
THAT WAS A HUGE ISSUE WHEN I
WAS THERE. AND IT ALWAYS MADE
ME FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE. A FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SPEAK.
ARM. HAVING SAID THAT ARE I
ALSO APPLIED. YOUR WORK AND
CERTAINLY STEP INTO THE SHOES
AS IT RELATES TO THE VICE CHAIR
RELY ON FOR THE LABORATORIES
AND- AND CERTAINLY
REPRESENTATIVE TAUSCHER IN THE
WORK THAT SHE DID. I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH HER A
NUMBER OF TIMES AND
SPECIFICALLY ON A NUMBER OF
THOSE ISSUES AND I THOUGHT SHE
WAS INCREDIBLY. I GIFTED. AND
SO FIVE BIG SHOES FOR YOU TO
FILL BUT IT'S QUITE AN HONOR TO
BE PUT IN THAT POSITION AND I'M
SURE. I. I THINK LASTLY I WOULD
JUST SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE I. HERE WE'VE WE'VE
DONE THESE APPOINTMENTS FOR THE
REGION'S TIME AND TIME AGAIN
AND IT'S ALWAYS REALLY.
INTERESTING TO HEAR. APPOINTEES
SPEAK BECAUSE ARE INEVITABLY
IT'S A LIFELONG DREAM OF
WHOEVER SITTING THERE TO
ACTUALLY SERVE ON THAT. BODY
AND SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT YOUR DEDICATION. AND
WITH THAT ARE I WILL SEE WHO IS
HERE IN SUPPORT THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK. YOUR FAMILY'S NODDING
THEIR HEAD. THEY'RE THEY'RE
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU FROM FROM
THE ROOF THE SECOND ROW IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SENATOR ROTH
HAS MOVED THE CONFIRMATION
MADAM SECRETARY. SENATORS BATES
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH I WILL WILK AYE
ATKINS AYE. CONGRATULATIONS
UNANIMOUS. THIS WAS A GOOD DAY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY
DON'T ALWAYS GO SO EASILY SO WE
DON'T AKE THESE MOMENTS FOR
GRANTED CONGRATULATIONS AND WE
WILL ADJOURN INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION MOMENTARILY AS PEOPLE
ARE